This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Every November, Americans gather together to celebrate important traditions. Shopping for doorbuster deals on 72-inch TVs, watching Snoopy Balloons float down 6th Avenue, and we eat a lot of food. Lots of food means lots of food waste. And so, after your Thanksgiving, you might find yourself hosting an unwanted second gathering. Raccoons rummaging in your garbage for discarded turkey and uneaten yams. Today we're presenting a remixed all-time favorite story we ran for Thanksgiving 2018. It's about our friendly neighbors up north and their attempt to defend themselves from an invading army of trash pandas.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。每年11月，美国人都会聚在一起庆祝重要的传统。抢购 72 英寸电视的重磅折扣，看史努比气球漂过第六大道，我们还会吃大量的食物。大量的食物意味着大量的食物浪费。因此，在感恩节过后，你可能会发现自己迎来了意料之外的第二次聚会。浣熊在你的垃圾桶里翻找扔掉的火鸡和没吃完的红薯。今天我们带来的是我们在 2018 年感恩节播出的一个备受喜爱的重混故事。它讲的是我们北方的友好邻居，以及他们试图抵御入侵的“垃圾熊猫”大军的尝试。
Enjoy. The City of Toronto has a special relationship with raccoons, or at least they think they do. We are not the only city with raccoons, but we often act like we are. We like to think Toronto is the raccoon capital of the world, and we're strangely proud of that distinction. But we really have no data to back it up. This is Amy Dempsey, a reporter for the Toronto Star.
请欣赏。多伦多市与浣熊有着一种特殊的联系，或者至少他们自己是这么认为的。我们并不是唯一有浣熊的城市，但我们常常表现得好像是。我们喜欢认为多伦多是世界的浣熊之都，而且我们对这种殊荣有着奇怪的自豪感。但我们其实没有任何数据来支持这一点。我是《多伦多星报》的记者艾米·登普西。
Do we have more raccoons than, say, Chicago or Vancouver? Well, we don't actually know. You can't count urban raccoons. They Chicago or Vancouver? Well, we don't actually know. You can't count urban raccoons, they're all over the place. But who needs data when you can feel it in your heart? A few years ago when a raccoon died on Yonge Street, Torontonians named him Conrad and built a vigil around his body with flowers
我们的浣熊比芝加哥或温哥华多吗？嗯，我们其实并不知道。你没法统计城市的浣熊。它们芝加哥或温哥华？嗯，我们其实并不知道。你没法统计城市的浣熊，它们到处都是。但是，当你能在心中感受到它时，谁还需要数据呢？几年前，当一只浣熊在央街（Yonge Street）死去时，多伦多人为它取名叫康拉德（Conrad），并在它的尸体周围用鲜花建立了一个悼念区
and a framed photo and cards. So if science ever disproves this idea of Toronto as raccoon nation, I really fear for Toronto I think we're gonna have an identity crisis. But Toronto's feelings about raccoons are not uncomplicated. Our relationship with raccoons is kind of a love-hate relationship. We hate when they destroy our grass and break into our houses, and yes they do break into our houses. Maybe worse than all this though, was the raccoons' proclivity for getting into the compost,
以及一张带框的照片和卡片。所以，如果科学最终驳斥了多伦多是浣熊之国的这种想法，我真的为多伦多感到担心，我觉得我们将面临身份危机。但多伦多对浣熊的感情并非那么简单。我们与浣熊的关系有点像爱恨交织。我们讨厌它们破坏草坪、闯入我们的房子，是的，它们确实会闯入我们的房子。不过，也许比这更糟糕的是，浣熊有喜欢钻进堆肥桶的癖好，
which the city started collecting for the residents in green bins several years ago. From the perspective of the raccoons, these compost bins were an incredible development, an all-you-can-eat buffet with the plastic and other garbage already thoughtfully removed. And the raccoons would go to town on our stuff and just spread it everywhere. And you'd wake up, look out your window and go, s***.
几年前，多伦多市开始用绿色的垃圾桶为居民收集这种垃圾。在浣熊看来，这些堆肥桶简直是个了不起的发明，是一个自助餐，而且塑料和其他垃圾都已经被人贴心地清理掉了。浣熊们会在我们的东西里大快朵颐，然后把它们弄得到处都是。第二天早上醒来，你往窗外一看，就会说：靠。
And then maybe you'd argue with your spouse or roommates about who'd have to clean it up. The green bins become a feast, a veritable feast for the raccoons. This is Toronto Mayor John Tory, a few years ago, dressed in a blue suit in front of a row of Canadian flags, as if he's announcing a plan to step up the war on crime. And in a way, he was. Nothing that represents more of a nuisance in a big city like this than the feasting of the raccoons on the contents of the green bins.
然后你可能会和你的配偶或室友争论到底该轮到谁来打扫。绿色垃圾桶变成了一场盛宴，一场名副其实的浣熊盛宴。这是多伦多市长庄德利（John Tory）几年前身穿蓝色西装、站在一排加拿大国旗前的画面，那架势仿佛他要宣布一项加大打击犯罪力度的计划。从某种意义上说，他确实是这么打算的。在大城市里，没有什么比浣熊在绿色垃圾桶的内容物里大快朵颐更能带来麻烦的了。
The war on raccoons sort of started with Mayor John Tory. We've discovered that the members of Raccoon Nation are smart, they're hungry, and they're determined. But our job, together with our private sector reinforcements, is to show them that we are smarter. He said things like... We are ready, we are armed, we are motivated. We have left no stone unturned in our fight against Raccoon Nation. The reason Mayor Tory felt so prepared that day was that the city was unveiling a new raccoon-resistant green bin for organic waste. During this same press conference, the mayor
这场针对浣熊的战争某种程度上是由市长庄德利挑起的。我们已经发现，“浣熊国”的成员们很聪明、很饥饿、而且意志坚定。但我们的任务，连同我们私营部门的增援力量，就是要向它们证明我们更聪明。他说过这样的话……我们已经准备好了，我们武装好了，我们充满动力。在打击“浣熊国”的斗争中，我们已经掘地三尺，不遗余力。庄德利市长那天之所以感到准备如此充分，是因为该市正在推出一款针对有机垃圾的新型防浣熊绿色垃圾桶。在同一次新闻发布会上，市长
held up the new bin victoriously and hammed it up with reporters as cameras flashed. No David. Hahaha. I would say it was 75% tongue in cheek, but there was also a hint of seriousness to it. It was pretty clear that he was confident the new green bins would solve our raccoon problems. Confident enough to stand in front of news cameras and say, you know, defeat is not an option. But Amy was about to find out for herself whether defeat was an option and spoiler alert, it was an option.
在闪光灯闪烁的同时，胜利地举起了新垃圾桶，并在记者面前夸张地表演了一番。不，大卫。哈哈哈哈。我会说这有 75% 是在开玩笑，但其中也夹杂着一丝认真。很明显，他很有信心，相信新的绿色垃圾桶能解决我们的浣熊问题。他自信到敢于站在新闻摄像机前说，你知道的，认输不是选项。但艾米很快就要亲自弄清楚认输到底是不是一个选项了——剧透一下，这确实是一个选项。
Let's back up just a bit. This all started the way most things start in cities with an RFP.PDF. Yeah, they put out a request for proposals asking for a new generation green bin and emphasizing that it had to be rodent resistant, aka animal resistant, aka raccoon proof please. The company that won was called Rare Rig Pacific. I'm Dennis Monastir with Rare Rig Pacific and I serve as the environmental sales manager for Canada. If the city of Toronto was in a war with raccoons, this ladies and gentlemen was the general in charge of a major front and he
让我们稍微回顾一下。这一切的开始就像城市里大多数事情的开始一样——通过一份 RFP（招标书）PDF。对，他们发布了一份征求建议书，要求设计新一代的绿色垃圾桶，并强调它必须具备防啮齿动物的功能，也就是防动物，也就是请做到防浣熊。中标的公司叫拉里克太平洋（Rarig Pacific）。我是拉里克太平洋公司的丹尼斯·莫纳斯蒂尔（Dennis Monastir），我担任加拿大的环境销售经理。如果多伦多市是在与浣熊打仗，那么女士们先生们，这位就是负责前线重任的将军，他
took his role very seriously. I mean Rareig Pacific takes new product development very, very seriously. And there's a five pronged approach, which we initiate. Dennis is in many ways a classic sales guy. He wears shirts with his company logo. He has a firm handshake. I found him to be extremely helpful and genuine. And when he speaks about the green bin, you can tell he's really proud of it.
非常认真地对待自己的角色。我是说，拉里克太平洋公司对待新产品开发非常、非常认真。我们启动了一种五管齐下的方法。丹尼斯在许多方面都是个典型的销售员。他穿着印有公司标志的衬衫。他的握手很有力。我发现他极其乐于助人且真诚。当他谈到这个绿色垃圾桶时，你能看出他是真的为此感到自豪。
It's something that I'm very, very passionate about, not only being part of the design team, but I'm also a resident in the City of Toronto. So I know what it means to me as a resident. Rarick Pacific had a number of design criteria they were trying to meet with their green bin prototype. For example, the bins would need to be picked up and dumped by an automatic arm that reached
这是我非常、非常热爱的事情，我不仅是设计团队的一员，而且我也是多伦多市的居民。所以我知道它对作为居民的我意味着什么。拉里克太平洋公司在设计绿色垃圾桶原型时，尝试满足了多项设计标准。例如，垃圾桶需要能够被从卡车伸出的
out from the truck. So the bin would need a lid that closed and locked to protect against raccoons, but the lid would also have to open up automatically when the bin was turned upside down and dumped into the truck by the arm. So we had to ensure that the lock itself disengages 100% of the time. The container must function in extreme weather conditions. Ergonomics, easily open with one single hand. We were looking at, you know, safety. Kids end up in the darndest places. Definitely don't want them in an organics container, but more importantly, we don't want them locked inside the container. Elimination of
自动机械臂拾取并倾倒。因此，垃圾桶需要一个能够闭合和锁定的盖子来防范浣熊，但当垃圾桶被机械臂倒置倾倒进卡车时，盖子也必须能够自动打开。所以我们必须确保锁扣本身在 100% 的情况下都能解开。容器必须能够在极端天气条件下运作。人体工程学，用单手就能轻松打开。我们考虑到了，你知道的，安全。小孩子们总是会去到最意想不到的地方。绝对不想让他们掉进有机垃圾容器里，但更重要的是，我们不希望他们被锁在容器内部。消除
internal catch points. Any material that becomes trapped inside the container could pose significant risk with respect to the IC factor for the residents. But on top of the IC factor and the meddling kids, Rarik Pacific had to think about enemy number one, the raccoons. Eric Pacific had to think about enemy number one, the raccoons. Yeah, so we worked with an urban raccoon specialist to basically understand, um, raccoons likes, dislikes, their dexterity, what they can and cannot do.
内部卡点。任何被困在容器内部的材料，都可能给居民带来巨大的“恶心”因素风险。但除了“恶心”因素和爱捣蛋的小孩之外，拉里克太平洋公司还必须考虑头号敌人——浣熊。拉里克太平洋公司还必须考虑头号敌人——浣熊。是的，所以我们与一位城市浣熊专家合作，基本上是为了解，嗯，浣熊的喜好、厌恶、它们的灵巧度，它们能做什么和不能做什么。
It was a local raccoon specialist by the name of Suzanne McDonald. I'm Dr. Suzanne McDonald. I'm a professor at York university. I study animal behavior. I'm calling her a McDonald. I'm a professor at York University. I study animal behavior. I'm calling her a raccoon specialist, really downplays her accomplishments. She is a professor of biology and psychology who has studied just about every animal you can think of. She may have studied every animal you can think of,
那是一位当地的浣熊专家，名叫苏珊·麦克唐纳（Suzanne McDonald）。我是苏珊·麦克唐纳博士。我是约克大学的教授。我研究动物行为。我称她为麦克唐纳。我是约克大学的教授。我研究动物行为。我称她为浣熊专家，真的贬低了她的成就。她是一位生物学和心理学教授，研究过你能想到的几乎所有动物。她可能研究过你能想到的所有动物，
but in Toronto, there's only one animal that matters. In Toronto, everybody talks about raccoons. I work in Vancouver a lot and nobody talks about raccoons there. There's raccoons all the time. So she wasn't that surprised when Rarik Pacific got in touch as they were designing their bin. And they asked me to talk to them about how raccoons work and I did. Well, raccoons are omnivores, so that means they can eat everything.
但在多伦多，只有一个动物是重要的。在多伦多，每个人都在谈论浣熊。我在温哥华工作很多，那里没有人谈论浣熊。那里的浣熊一直都有。所以当拉里克太平洋公司在设计垃圾桶时与她取得联系时，她并没有那么惊讶。他们请我跟他们谈谈浣熊是如何运作的，我就去了。嗯，浣熊是杂食动物，这意味着它们什么都能吃。
They're mischievous. Raccoons have really good teeth. They'll use them. They don't want to use them. They want you to go away. You go away? You're in my yard. They also get a taste for human food.
它们很顽皮。浣熊的牙齿非常好。它们会用这些牙齿。它们不想用。它们想让你走开。你走开？你在我的院子里。它们对人类的食物也很感兴趣。
So once they get a taste for that Indian takeout that we've thrown out that they've enjoyed, from then on it's like berries. I'm not eating berries. We look at them, they look at us. If you would look at a monkey in the face, they'll look away. But raccoons don't. They look right at us. They look right through us.
所以一旦它们尝到了我们扔掉的、它们很喜欢的印度外卖的滋味，从那以后这就跟浆果一样了。我不吃浆果。我们看着它们，它们看着我们。如果你看着一只猴子的脸，它们会把视线移开。但浣熊不会。它们直直地看着我们。它们仿佛能看穿我们。
You know, they have pretty good senses of smell. They have pretty good vision. But touch is their superpower. They're very persistent. They will work at a problem for hours and hours and hours. And they're pretty strong. Rarick Pacific took all of this information and applied it to their bin design. There was multiple iterations of the design.
你知道的，它们的嗅觉相当好。它们的视力相当好。但触觉是它们的超能力。它们非常执着。它们会针对一个问题琢磨几个小时、几个小时、几个小时。而且它们力气很大。拉里克太平洋公司采纳了所有这些信息，并将其应用到了垃圾桶的设计中。该设计经历了好几次迭代。
There's multiple photorealistic renderings. In the end, they came out with a bin they believed in. It's an olive green, 26 gallon container with a lid that closes and locks. We felt very, very confident with the success of that locking mechanism and the container itself. So the new green bin rollout took about 18 months from start to finish.
有多个逼真的渲染图。最后，他们推出了一款他们深信不疑的垃圾桶。这是一个橄榄绿的、容量为 26 加仑的容器，带有一个可以闭合和锁定的盖子。我们对该锁定机制和容器本身的成功感到非常、非常自信。因此，新型绿色垃圾桶的推广从头到尾大约花了 18 个月。
People are waiting for their new green bins, and people are getting really excited about these things. Before they were rolled out on my street, they were rolled out on some of the streets nearby, so people on my street would have to walk by and see that homes near us had the new green bin and we didn't. And you'd sort of be thinking on your walk to the subway
人们在等待他们的新绿色垃圾桶，人们对这些东西感到非常兴奋。在它们在我这条街上推广之前，它们已经在附近的一些街道上推广了，所以我这条街上的人走过时，会看到我们附近的房子有了新的绿色垃圾桶，而我们却没有。而在你走去地铁站
to go to work, like, what the hell? Where's my bin? But eventually, Amy did get a bin of her own so on the lid there is a dial like a handle that you turn and When it's in the horizontal position, it's open when it's in the vertical position It's secured. It's locked. You actually have to turn it in a way that really would make it difficult, if not impossible, to turn if you don't have opposable thumbs. And contrary to popular belief, raccoons don't have opposable thumbs, even though they can
上班的路上，你心里会想，搞什么鬼？我的垃圾桶呢？但最终，艾米确实拿到了自己的垃圾桶。所以盖子上有一个像把手一样的旋钮，你可以转动它。当它处于水平位置时，它是打开的；当它处于垂直位置时，它是固定的。它是锁上的。你实际上必须以一种真正会让人难以转动——如果你没有对生拇指的话，甚至是不可能转动——的方式来转动它。而且与普遍看法相反，浣熊没有对生拇指，尽管它们可以用它们
move the thumb-like digit on their creepy little hands a little bit. In any case, for a while, everything seemed to be going according to plan. In fact, some people were worried that the new bins were working too well. In other words, people were afraid that without the green bins as a food source, maybe the raccoons were starving. So the way I became involved in all of this was that in January of 2018, a friend sent me a note saying that he believed the new green bins had eliminated the raccoon population in Toronto. He actually used the word eliminated.
那毛骨悚然的小手上类似拇指的指头稍微动一动。无论如何，有一段时间，一切似乎都按计划进行。事实上，有些人担心新的绿色垃圾桶工作得太好了。换句话说，人们担心没有了绿色垃圾桶作为食物来源，浣熊可能会挨饿。所以我是怎么卷入这一切的呢：在 2018 年 1 月，一个朋友给我发了一条便条，说他相信新的绿色垃圾桶已经消灭了多伦多的浣熊种群。他用的词其实是“消灭”。
As any intrepid reporter would do, Amy decided to look into it. I wrote a quick email to Suzanne McDonald, our local raccoon expert, and I said, Hey, could the raccoons be dying? And she just said, yeah, they're probably hiding from the cold. But she said she would have more information in a few months. She said, after I measure more dead raccoons. So I, of course, wrote back immediately and said, can I come? Animal control was collecting raccoons killed by cars
正如任何一个勇敢无畏的记者会做的那样，艾米决定对此进行调查。我给我们的当地浣熊专家苏珊·麦克唐纳写了一封简短的电子邮件，我说，嘿，浣熊会死掉吗？她只是说，是的，它们可能在躲避严寒。但她说她几个月后会有更多信息。她说，在我测量了更多死浣熊之后。所以，我当然立刻回信说，我可以去吗？动物管制部门正在收集被汽车撞死的浣熊，
and storing them in freezers for Suzanne, who would then come in and measure them in order to track the health of the population from year to year. And I do this four times a year. And when you go in July, it turns out, and you bring out frozen raccoon carcasses and it takes a while to measure them,
并将它们储存在冰柜里留给苏珊，苏珊随后会去测量它们，以便追踪该物种一年接一年健康状况。我一年做四次这个。而当你七月份去的时候，事实证明，当你拿出冷冻的浣熊尸体，花上一段时间去测量它们时，
they start to melt. Oh dear God, you can imagine the maggots and the blood and all the things. But that's fine. I mean, this is science. We push through. Suzanne wouldn't have the results of her data for a while. But while Amy was there watching her measure dead raccoons, she asked her, Do you think it's possible they could learn how to get into the new green bins? And she shook her head no. She said, you know, she'd filmed them trying and not one of them could do it. She just said, they won't get in.
它们开始融化了。哦天哪，你可以想象那些蛆虫、血液和各种东西。但没关系。我是说，这是科学。我们坚持下去。苏珊的 数据结果还要过一段时间才能出来。但当艾米在那里看着她测量死浣熊时，她问她：“你觉得它们有可能学会如何打开新的绿色垃圾桶吗？”她摇了摇头。她说，你知道的，她拍过它们尝试的视频，没有一只能够做到。她只是说，它们进不去的。
The raccoons won't break into these green bins. There is no such thing as a raccoon-proof green bin. Toronto spent a lot of money on the raccoon-proof green bins. And this was video that was put out yesterday. So I come out. Then about a week later, this story comes out. And so look to your left. So watch as they'll zoom into it here.
浣熊是不会闯进这些绿色垃圾桶里的。世上根本没有什么防浣熊的绿色垃圾桶。多伦多在防浣熊绿色垃圾桶上花了很多钱。这是昨天发布的一段视频。所以我走出来了。然后大约一周后，这个故事出来了。所以看你的左边。看它们在这里放大。
Hold on. It's basically a local Toronto resident who has filmed a video of a raccoon opening his green bin. Yeah, let's give that a little tug. There we go. Something smells good. And just like kind of's give that a little tug. — There we go. — Well, something smells good. — And just, like, kind of winking at the camera almost.
等一下。基本上是多伦多当地的一位居民拍了一段浣熊打开他的绿色垃圾桶的视频。是的，让我们稍微拉一下那个。这就对了。有什么东西闻起来很香。就像那种……稍微拉一下。——好了。——嗯，有什么东西闻起来很香。——就像，几乎是在对镜头眨眼。
— Really? — Ha ha ha ha ha. — This was not the only report of a bin being broken into, although it was the first to include video which quickly went viral, much to the dismay of Dennis Monastir from Rarig, Pacific. — For somebody just to come out and say, oh, the container doesn't work, um, you know, is frustrating.
——真的吗？——哈哈哈哈哈。——这并不是唯一关于垃圾桶被撬开的报道，尽管它是第一个包含视频的报道，而这段视频迅速在网上疯传，这让拉里克太平洋公司的丹尼斯·莫纳斯蒂尔感到非常沮丧。——对于有人直接跳出来说，哦，这个容器不管用，嗯，你知道的，这让人很沮丧。
The videos Dennis says don't tell the whole story. A couple of break-ins doesn't mean the design is flawed. The screw might be loosened too much. And if you just simply tighten it a little bit, it might prevent the issue. Dennis is frustrated by the fact that sometimes when people have issues with their green bins, they don't call the city, they don't report their issues to 311. Instead, they sometimes call the local newspaper and then it becomes a story.
丹尼斯说，这些视频并不能说明全部情况。几次入室盗窃并不意味着设计有缺陷。螺丝可能松得太多了。如果你稍微把它拧紧一点，可能就能解决这个问题。让丹尼斯感到沮丧的是，有时人们在使用绿色垃圾桶遇到问题时，他们不打电话给城市，不向 311 报告他们的问题。相反，他们有时会打电话给当地报纸，然后这就变成了一则新闻。
I think he said something to me like, you know, when your car breaks down, you don't call the Toronto Star, you call the mechanic. I don't know, for some reason, you know, Toronto specifically, they love to glamorize raccoons. The city for its part, blamed the handful of break-ins on user error. And the city's response was to suggest that these homeowners weren't locking their bins properly and to emphasize they had only had a handful of complaints out of 450,000 green bins. The suggestion being that if Joe in Yorkville had a problem with his bin, then maybe the problem was Joe and not the bin.
我想他对我说过这样的话，你知道的，当你的车抛锚时，你不会给《多伦多星报》打电话，你会给机械师打电话。我不知道，出于某种原因，你知道的，多伦多特有的就是，他们喜欢把浣熊浪漫化。多伦多市政府则将这起零星的撬门入室归咎于用户操作失误。市政府的回应是暗示这些房主没有正确锁好垃圾桶，并强调在 45 万个绿色垃圾桶中，他们只收到了寥寥可数的几起投诉。言下之意是，如果约克维尔（Yorkville）的乔对他的垃圾桶有意见，那么有问题的人也许是乔，而不是垃圾桶。
So soon after, I woke up one morning and walked outside and saw that my neighbor's green bin was on the ground in our laneway and there was food everywhere. So I texted my neighbor and said, the raccoons have gotten into your green bin. She said, you know, what the hell can the raccoons get into the green bins now? At this point, Amy had been convinced by the city's argument. There was no problem with the bins. The problem was the users. I wrote back and said, more likely that you didn't lock it properly.
不久之后，我某天早晨醒来，走到户外，看到我邻居的绿色垃圾桶倒在我们巷子里，食物弄得到处都是。所以我给邻居发短信说，浣熊进你的绿色垃圾桶了。她说，你知道的，搞什么鬼，浣熊现在能进绿色垃圾桶了吗？此时，艾米已经被市政府的论点说服了。垃圾桶没有问题。问题出在用户身上。我回信说，更有可能是你没把它锁好。
I still have the text message and when I read it, I cringe a little bit. It's like, no, I don't think you locked it properly, Caroline. But Amy didn't get to stay smug for long. Two nights later, her own bin was plundered. My husband and I get a group text message from Caroline. The raccoons have gotten into your green bin. At this point I'm floored because my husband is a person who locks things and checks locks like seven times.
我还留着那条短信，当我读到它时，我有点感到难为情。就好像，不，我觉得你没锁好，卡洛琳。但艾米并没有得意太久。两天后，她自己的垃圾桶也被洗劫了。我和丈夫收到了卡洛琳发来的群发短信。浣熊进你们的绿色垃圾桶了。此时我彻底惊呆了，因为我丈夫是一个会锁门并且检查七遍锁的人。
It seemed the reporter had just become a character in her own story. I'm thinking like first of all, do they, like this is so weird. Do they know that I was looking into this stuff? You know, am I being targeted? Amy called the city who said, ma'am, please, you probably just have a broken handle. And they sent some workers out to fix it. And they replaced the lid on my bin as a precaution,
看来这位记者刚刚成了自己故事里的一个角色。我心想，首先，它们会吗，这太奇怪了。它们知道我在调查这些东西吗？你知道的，我是不是被盯上了？艾米给市政府打了电话，市政府说：女士，拜访您放尊重点，您可能只是有个坏把手。他们派了一些工人来修理。作为预防措施，他们更换了我垃圾桶的盖子，
even though they couldn't find anything wrong with it. She also wrote to the Raccoon expert, Suzanne McDonald, who was thrilled because she's always secretly been on Team Raccoon. She wrote back almost immediately and said, that is awesome. And she said, I'm going to loan you a trail camera and you have to see how they're doing it.
尽管他们找不到任何毛病。她还写信给浣熊专家苏珊·麦克唐纳，苏珊听后欣喜若狂，因为她一直暗中支持“浣熊战队”。她几乎立刻回信说，太棒了。她说，我要借给你一台野径相机，你必须去看看它们是怎么做到的。
So I get the camera from Suzanne. We meet up at the zoo one day. I go to our local grocery store and I get a couple of chickens. Put the chicken in the green bin, rubbed some of the chicken grease all over the green bin. The first night raccoons did not come. The second night I went out to the front porch actually with my toddler. We peeked around the corner and my my daughter said, uh-oh. The bin was down. It was a mess. I took the camera upstairs and pressed play on the video that I captured. It's almost as though the raccoons knew what
所以我从苏珊那里拿到了相机。有一天我们在动物园碰面。我去了当地的杂货店，买了几只鸡。把鸡放进绿色垃圾桶里，把一些鸡油涂满了整个绿色垃圾桶。第一天晚上，浣熊没有来。第二天晚上，我其实带着我的幼儿来到了前廊。我们探头看了看拐角处，我的女儿说，哎呀。垃圾桶倒了。一团糟。我把相机拿上楼，按下了我捕捉到的视频的播放键。几乎就好像浣熊知道
I was doing and they were like, let's give her a really good shot here. This one is going to go viral. Camera is pointing at the bins and then all of a sudden this this mama raccoon comes skulking out and she just pulls the bin down like and she she gets out of the way like at this point you can tell she knows what she's doing like she's not gonna stand in the way and get crushed by the bin. No. She's gonna pull it at the exact right angle and it just falls down with like a BAM! And turns around and looks at the camera as if to say, watch this.
我在做什么，它们当时的想法是：给她来个特写吧。这个视频要火了。相机正对着垃圾桶，然后突然之间，这只母浣熊鬼鬼祟祟地出来了，她就这样把垃圾桶拉倒了，就像这样，然后她闪到了一边，从这一点你可以看出她知道自己在做什么，她可不会挡在路中间被垃圾桶压扁。不。她会以完全正确的角度拉动它，然后它就“砰”的一声倒下了！接着它转过身看着镜头，仿佛在说：看这个。
And then she turns the handle and just opens it, yoink, opens it just like I would. And in they go. The keys seem to be knocking down the bin, which made the handle much easier to turn. When it's on the ground, you can just kind of pull on it, like as if you're pulling a lever. You know, you can almost bat your paws at it or like pull it to the side. On August 30th, 2018, Amy published an article in the Toronto Star with her video, and as
然后它转动把手，就这样打开了——“哟”，像我一样轻轻松松地打开了。然后它们就进去了。关键似乎是把垃圾桶推倒，这使得把手更容易转动。当它倒在地上时，你就可以直接拉它，就像拉一个杠杆一样。你知道的，你几乎可以用爪子拍打它，或者把它往侧面拉。2018年8月30日，艾米在《多伦多星报》上发表了一篇文章并附上了她的视频，正如
these things tend to do in Toronto, it went viral. Thousands of Torontonians watched as the protagonist handily pulled down the bin and then, flashing her glowing eyes at the camera, showed off how easily she could open it. Amy got a bunch of emails and comments on the article, people saying that this was happening to them too, but the city maintained they were getting relatively few complaints overall. When Amy told Dennis Montesier from Rarik Pacific that the raccoons were getting into the bin that his company designed, he decided to pay her a house call.
多伦多的这类事情一样，它火遍了全网。成千上万的多伦多市民看着主角轻巧地拉倒垃圾桶，然后对着镜头闪烁着发光的眼睛，展示着她是多么轻易地就能将它打开。艾米收到了许多关于这篇文章的电子邮件和评论，人们说这种事也在他们身上发生，但市政府坚称他们收到的总体投诉相对较少。当艾米告诉拉里克太平洋公司的丹尼斯·莫纳斯蒂尔说浣熊溜进了他公司设计的垃圾桶时，他决定亲自去她家拜访。
You know, I personally wanted to go out there myself to inspect the container and to do some torque force testing on the handle itself. Some heroes don't wear capes. They wear polo shirts with the company logo on the breast pocket. The day Dennis came over, my neighbor Mike came over as soon as he saw this guy in my driveway working on the green bin. But Mike had no idea that this is the green bin guy. It seemed like there was a gang of neighbors
你知道的，我个人想亲自去那里检查容器，并对把手本身进行扭力测试。有些英雄不穿披风。他们穿着胸前口袋印有公司标志的Polo衫。丹尼斯过来的那天，我的邻居迈克一看到这个人在我车道上修理绿色垃圾桶就过来了。但迈克并不知道这就是“绿色垃圾桶先生”。感觉好像有一帮邻居
that came up all of a sudden out of nowhere. And it was just like, oh, we have some problems with the raccoons getting into our bins. Getting into my bin, they're getting into everybody's bin. And he's just ripping on the green bins and the waste of money. Dennis took it all like a champ. He tightened up everyone's handles
不知从哪里突然冒了出来。情况就像是，哦，我们确实有一些浣熊溜进我们垃圾桶的问题。溜进我的垃圾桶，它们溜进了所有人的垃圾桶。而他正在疯狂吐槽绿色垃圾桶和白白浪费金钱。丹尼斯像个男子汉一样坦然接受了这一切。他把每个人的把手都拧紧了，
so they'd be particularly hard for little raccoon paws to turn. But it hasn't solved the problem. Having accepted defeat, Amy now keeps her bins tied to a wall so raccoons can't knock them over. And she can't help but wonder how soon before this knowledge about how to open the bins spreads to the rest of Raccoon Nation.
这样小浣熊爪子就很难转动它们了。但这并没有解决问题。在接受了失败之后，艾米现在把她的垃圾桶绑在墙上，这样浣熊就没法把它们推倒了。她不禁琢磨，这种关于如何打开垃圾桶的知识要花多久才会传到“浣熊国”的其他地方。
Raccoons don't teach each other these things. It's called social learning and even most monkeys don't do that. And so it's not like this innovation is going to spread across the city. Suzanne McDonald doesn't think most raccoons in Toronto currently have what it takes to get into the new green compost bins. That perfect combination of strength, intelligence, and determination. Amy just happened to encounter an extra gifted one. We call her the genius raccoon because I think it's amazing that she did it.
浣熊不会互相教这些东西。这被称为社会性学习，甚至大多数猴子都不会这样做。所以这种创新并不会在全市范围内传播开来。苏珊·麦克唐纳认为，目前多伦多的大多数浣熊并没有能力打开新的绿色堆肥桶。那种力量、智慧和决心的完美结合。艾米只是恰巧遇到了一只天赋异禀的。我们称她为主神浣熊，因为我觉得她能做到这一点太了不起了。
Suzanne finally finished her dead raccoon study, and Toronto's favorite frenemy is as fat as ever. She thinks that's because even though most of them can't get into the compost, they've moved on to a different solution. The good old-fashioned garbage. Our raccoons are not starving to death, that's for sure. But she doesn't rule out that in a far-off future we might end up creating an uber raccoon, one like Amy's that can get into just about anything. She's studied raccoons in
苏珊终于完成了她的死浣熊研究，多伦多最喜欢的“亦敌亦友”依然像以前一样胖。她认为这是因为，尽管它们大多数人打不开堆肥桶，但它们已经转向了另一种解决方案。好那种老式的垃圾。我们的浣熊绝对没有饿死，那是肯定的。但她并不排除在遥远的未来，我们最终可能会创造出一只超级浣熊——一只像艾米遇到的那样，几乎能打开任何东西的浣熊。她研究过
cities and they are, on the whole, smarter than their rural counterparts. Urban raccoons are constantly having new problems placed in front of them to solve and they keep figuring them out. And Suzanne and Dennis both tell people that the green bins were never advertised as raccoon proof, only raccoon resistant. Nothing is raccoon proof, they say, which is a small concession that while the front of the line is holding for now,
城市的浣熊，总体而言，它们比农村的同类更聪明。城市的浣熊不断面临需要解决的新问题，而且它们总能想出解决办法。苏珊和丹尼斯都告诉人们，绿色垃圾桶从来没有被宣传为“防浣熊”，而只是“抗浣熊”。他们说，没有什么东西是绝对防浣熊的，这是一个微小的让步，虽然前线目前还在坚守，
the war against raccoons continues. After the break, more Raccoon Hijinks with Kirk Kolstad. If you listen to the show regularly, you know that Kurt Kohlstedt has a background in architecture. But if you also read the articles on our site, you probably also know that he's really into raccoons too. So when these two interests intersect, like say a raccoon going viral on the internet for climbing up a downtown St. Paul office tower earlier this year, he was all over that story.
但与浣熊的战争仍在继续。休息过后，还有更多柯克·科尔斯蒂特（Kirk Kolstad）带来的浣熊趣事。如果你经常收听这个节目，你就会知道柯克·科尔斯蒂特有建筑学背景。但如果你也阅读我们网站上的文章，你大概也知道他同样非常痴迷于浣熊。所以，当这两个兴趣交汇时——比如今年早些时候，一只浣熊因爬上市中心圣保罗（St. Paul）的一座办公大楼而在互联网上走红——他立刻就关注了这个故事。
Oh yeah, instantly. You know, the local news is there covering the story, on the scene, in Minnesota. But I'm out here, you know, researching the actual building that the raccoon is climbing. And I got super into it. I was analyzing the facade and the materials. I started diagramming and then deconstructing the route that this raccoon took to the top. And so if you want like a straight up Kennedy assassination style deconstruction of that whole saga, you can check out our website.
哦，是的，立刻。你知道的，当地新闻在那里报道这个故事，在明尼苏达州的现场。但我却在这里，你知道的，研究那只浣熊正在爬的那栋真实的建筑。我超级投入。我在分析立面和材料。我开始画图解，然后解构这只浣熊爬到顶部的路线。所以，如果你想要那种肯尼迪遇刺风格的整场事件的直接解构，你可以查看我们的网站。
But before we get too far off track, Kurt is here today with a story of a different famous raccoon from nearly a century ago, one that eventually resided in a particularly famous work of American architecture, the White House. Oh yes. History is not exactly full of famous raccoons, but there's this one in particular that really stands out, especially around Thanksgiving. Her name was Rebecca, and in 1926, she was sent to President Calvin Coolidge as a gift from a constituent in Mississippi.
但在我们扯得太远之前，柯克今天带来了一个关于近一个世纪前另一只著名浣熊的故事，它最终居住在了一处非常著名的美国建筑杰作中——白宫。哦，是的。历史并不完全充满着著名的浣熊，但确实有这么一只特别突出，尤其是在感恩节前后。她的名字叫丽贝卡（Rebecca），在 1926 年，她作为密西西比州选民的礼物被送给了卡尔文·柯立芝总统。
But this raccoon wasn't meant to be a pet. The idea was actually that she'd be served up as part of the holiday feast. Which is not the most traditional Thanksgiving meal. No, no. I mean, not today at least, but a century ago, wild animals were much more common to see on dinner plates. Meals with duck or turtle or possum were pretty typical, and in some cases they were even regional delicacies.
但这只浣熊并不是作为宠物送来的。其实原本的想法是把它作为节日盛宴的一部分端上餐桌。这可不是最传统的感恩节大餐。不，不。我是说，至少现在不是了，但在一个世纪前，在餐盘里看到野生动物要常见得多。吃鸭肉、海龟肉或负鼠肉相当普遍，在某些情况下，它们甚至算得上是地方美味。
And then also, sending animals as food to the White House for the holidays was a pretty popular tradition. So the president getting sent a raccoon wasn't maybe not that odd, but him keeping him as a pet was out of the ordinary. Right. I mean, that's a little bit more unusual. When we think about presidents and Thanksgiving, we usually think of that turkey pardoning tradition and that's about it.
此外，在节日期间向白宫送动物作为食物是一个相当受欢迎的传统。所以总统被送一只浣熊可能并不那么奇怪，但他把它当宠物养就有些不同寻常了。没错。我是说，这更不同寻常一点。当我们想到总统和感恩节时，我们通常会想到火鸡特赦传统，也就仅此而已了。
But for Coolidge, it wasn't that weird. He and his wife had tons of pets. They had cats and dogs and birds, of course, but also these really exotic ones. Over the years, they got wallabies and a bear, a pair of lion cubs, even a pygmy hippo. Most of these, you know, as gifts, often from, you know, foreign dignitaries
但对柯立芝来说，这并不算太奇怪。他和他的妻子养了成吨的宠物。他们有猫、狗和鸟，当然，还有这些非常异国情调的动物。这些年来，他们养过小袋鼠、一头熊、一对狮子幼崽，甚至还有一只侏儒河马。大多数这些动物，你知道的，都是作为礼物送的，通常来自，你知道的，外国政要，
who knew that the Coolidge's were really into weird animals. But I'm still having a hard time picturing, like, a pygmy hippo running around the White House. Right. Well, some of them they, you know, re-gifted to zoos that could actually take care of them. But the Coolages did keep a lot of them as pets and they formed this kind of weird White House menagerie or as one reporter called it, the Pennsylvania Avenue Zoo.
他们知道柯立芝夫妇非常喜欢奇怪的动物。但我还是很难想象，比如一只侏儒河马在白宫里跑来跑去。没错。嗯，他们中的一些人，你知道的，把它们转赠给了能够真正照顾它们的动物园。但柯立芝夫妇确实把很多动物当宠物养着，他们组成了这种奇怪的白宫动物园，或者正如一位记者所说的那样，宾夕法尼亚大道动物园。
And so what about Rebecca, the raccoon? Well, she became part of the first family, essentially. Grace, the first lady, would walk her around on a leash during the day, and then at night she'd curl up with Calvin on his lap next to the fireplace. That sounds like a pretty good pet. Well, yeah, I mean, that's one side of it. The other side is that she was still a wild animal, and she became kind of infamous for you know chewing her way out of her
那么浣熊丽贝卡呢？嗯，她基本上成了第一家庭的一员。第一夫人格雷丝（Grace）白天会用皮带牵着她在周围散步，到了晚上，她会蜷缩在卡尔文的腿上，依偎在壁炉旁。听起来是个相当不错的宠物。嗯，是的，我是说，这是一个方面。另一方面是她仍然是一只野生动物，并且因……你知道的，咬破并逃出
Enclosures and she'd wriggle out of the collars they put on her and she'd claw up the furniture in the White House there's these stories of the Secret Service having to chase her around while she runs up trees and Yeah, so she was a bit of a handful too But you know she got to hang out in the White House sometimes and the rest of the time she got this little wooden house That they put up for her on the South Lawn So she's a little bit of a hassle, but she seemed to have a pretty sweet life Rebecca the raccoon Yeah, she did and she lived with the Coolidge's for a while and then the first couple handed her off to a zoo and there were rumors at the time that
她的围栏而变得有点声名狼藉。她会从套在她身上的项圈里挣脱出来，把白宫的家具抓得稀巴烂。有这样的故事：特勤局不得不追着她到处跑，而她则往树上爬。是的，所以她也有点难以对付。但你知道的，她有时可以在白宫里闲逛，其余时间她在南草坪上为她搭建的小木屋里度过。所以她有点麻烦，但她似乎过着相当甜蜜的生活，浣熊丽贝卡。是的，她确实如此，她和柯立芝夫妇一起生活了一段时间，然后这对第一夫妇把她转交给了动物园。当时有传言说，
Maybe Rebecca bit Kelvin because one day he came out with a bandage on his hand But grace later wrote very fondly of this White House raccoon. According to her, Rebecca, quote, enjoyed nothing better than being placed in a bathtub with a little water in it and given a cake of soap with which to play. In this fashion, she would amuse herself for an hour or more. Wow. All right. Thank you, Kurt.
也许丽贝卡咬了卡尔文，因为有一天他手上缠着绷带出来。但格雷丝后来非常深情地写到了这只白宫浣熊。据她所说，丽贝卡“最喜欢的事莫过于被放进一个放了一点水的浴缸里，再给一块香皂让她玩耍。用这种方式，她能自娱自乐一个多小时。”哇。好吧。谢谢你，柯克。
Oh, yeah, of course. That episode originally aired in 2018, and as of this airing, Toronto has yet to declare victory in the war on raccoons. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Katie Mingle based on Amy Dempsey's epic raccoon story from the Toronto Star. You should really read the whole thing. It's great. We'll have a link on the website.
哦，是的，当然。那一集最初是在 2018 年播出的，截至本期节目播出时，多伦多尚未在对浣熊的战争中宣布胜利。本周的《99% Invisible》由凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）根据艾米·登普西在《多伦多星报》上关于浣熊的史诗级故事制作。你真的应该读读整篇文章。太棒了。我们会在网站上提供链接。
Original tech production by Sharif Youssef. Remix by Martine Gonzalez. Music by Swan Riel. This episode is dedicated to our digital director Kirk Holstead who enjoys nothing better than to be placed in a bathtub with a little water in it and given a cake of soap with which to play. Cathy Tu is our executive producer. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. Taylor Shedrick is our intern. The rest of the team includes Chris Berube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Ley, Lash Madon, Joe Rosenberg, Gabriella Gladney, Kelly Prime,
原创技术制作由谢里夫·优素福（Sharif Youssef）完成。重混由马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martine Gonzalez）制作。音乐由斯旺·里尔（Swan Riel）创作。本期节目献给我们的数字总监柯克·科尔斯蒂特，他最喜欢的事情莫过于被放进一个放了一点水的浴缸里，并获得一块香皂用来玩耍。凯茜·图（Cathy Tu）是我们的执行制片人。德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是我们的高级编辑。泰勒·谢德里克（Taylor Shedrick）是我们的实习生。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·贝鲁布（Chris Berube）、杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、维维安·雷（Vivian Ley）、拉什·马顿（Lash Madon）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼（Gabriella Gladney）、凯利·普赖姆（Kelly Prime）、
Nina Potok, Jaka Medina Gleason, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful. Uptown. Oakland, California. You can find us on our Discord server and also we just joined Blue Sky. I don't know.
尼娜·波托克（Nina Potok）、杰卡·梅迪纳·格利森（Jaka Medina Gleason），还有我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。99% Invisible 的标志是由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作的。我们是 Stitcher 和 SiriusXM 播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在北面六个街区外潘多拉大楼。位于美丽。加利福尼亚州奥克兰市的。上城区。你可以在我们的 Discord 服务器上找到我们，另外我们刚刚加入了 Blue Sky。我不知道。
We're going to give it a shot. Let's just try to make it good, okay? You can find us on our Discord server and also, we just joined Blue Sky, I don't know. We're gonna give it a shot. Let's just try to make it good, okay? You can find links to those social media sites plus some great pictures of the First Lady Grace Coolidge and her raccoon friend Rebecca, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们要尝试一下。让我们把它做好，好吗？你可以在我们的 Discord 服务器上找到这些社交媒体网站的链接，还有一些第一夫人格雷丝·柯立芝和她的浣熊朋友丽贝卡的精彩照片，以及 99PI 的所有往期节目，网址是 99PI.org。本期节目暂时还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。